[Music]
what's up guys i'm kbhd here okay so
huawei was in a really odd place in 2019
being banned in the us i did an entire
video about their
situation i'll leave that link right up
there so because of that every single
huawei phone that's come out since then
comes with like a giant asterisk next to
it at least in the us because it doesn't
make sense to buy here an android phone
without google play services and that
whole connection to android so their new
flagship came out and that's one of
those the huawei mate 30 pro
and i bought one but i didn't really get
to use it too much until now and it
turns out this is a really really nice
piece of hardware one of my favorites of
the year but it still can't make up for
this
software situation here's what i mean
just look at this phone this is actually
one of my favorite designs of all of
last year i've always been a fan of boxy
designs like i've said and this is one
of those but it's also quite unique
mainly because of this next level
waterfall display now i typically do not
like when phone displays curve a bit
over the edges like that's one of my
complaints for the oneplus 7 pro the
galaxy s10 a bunch of others
but this one is so dramatic it falls off
so steeply that it gives it that boxy
square look again it gives the phone an
actually pretty futuristic and
impressive look in the hand it's a six
and a half inch bright slightly above
1080p oled display it's got the
fingerprint reader underneath the glass
in the middle where it's reachable the
forehead and the chin are pretty thin
and the notch it isn't tiny but it isn't
as big as the iphone either and overall
it just makes for a nice viewing
experience unlike any other smartphone
that's come out but that is about where
the good stuff ends as far as the
display goes and then you start to
notice
the quirks as far as the quirks and
features first of all there is light
fall off on both edges it's kind of hard
to capture exactly what it looks like on
camera because the light still coming
from the oled seems to fill that in but
looking at it in person both sides of
the phone have this darker edge to them
and then the screen curves so far back
onto the side of the phone that it is
the side of the phone like it actually
is legitimately half of the side and
it's pushed that red power button all
the way to almost the back of the phone
it's like really offset from the center
line and since it's the only button on
the phone that you press every day you
definitely notice that and also as a
matter of fact it is
the only button on this entire phone
meaning there's no volume rocker so
instead you again use the side of the
phone and literally tap on the display
on the side and then swipe up and down
on that side part of the screen to
control the volume like it's a volume
rocker and then of course you get the
feeling of that haptic motor clicking as
you swipe and you can do it wherever you
want on the top half of the left or the
right side of the phone it is really
cool and it feels like a futuristic
solution to the problem but the more
times you use it the more times it fails
and or takes you two or three times to
activate it and then the more you just
wish you had a regular set of buttons
but the rest of this hardware is pretty
excellent though it's not too big of a
phone despite the huge screen size and
it feels solid and weighty in the hand
that's gorilla glass 6 in case you're
wondering since screen protectors are
probably not very protective on this
phone and you've got a good sized 4 500
milliamp hour battery that nets you
pretty great battery life there's an
optical fingerprint reader underneath
the display like i said nice and close
to the bottom so it's easy to reach and
works quickly and you do get 40 watt
wired fast charging and also 27 watt
fast wireless charging and reverse
wireless charging if you're into that
then the speaker at the bottom it's
small and kind of easily blocked but it
does get pretty loud and the whole phone
is ip68 water resistant and you even get
an ir blaster at the top remember these
from back in the day you can program
them to turn your tv on and off or just
troll other nearby people and turn their
tvs on and off really about the only
cons i can come up with for this phone's
hardware are nitpicks there's no
headphone jack which feels like a
nitpick in 2020 not a lot of phones in
this range have many more also the back
it's glass
and glass breaks but also that camera
bump is not small and it sticks out the
back of the phone a little bit in a way
that like catches a lot of lint because
it's a sharp edge and it's hard to get
the dust from around the circle if you
put it in your pocket even once the
expandable storage is via a proprietary
nano memory card so it's not a micro sd
card slot it's technically expandable
storage
but you might not be able to use the one
you currently have lying around and also
no higher fresh rate on the display
that is a nitpick for 2019
but coming into 2020 that's starting to
feel like a pretty big deal but other
than that you can clearly tell there's a
lot to like with this phone and it
doesn't just stop on the outside it gets
to the inside too you get the high
silicon karen 990 which if you haven't
heard of it is a high-end chip not quite
matching the power of the snapdragon 855
but very close and with eight gigs of
ram and ufs 3.0 storage this phone is
quick it's no slouch at all it games
just fine scrolls around multitasks as
good as any other 60hz phone and the
camera hardware is beastly 2. we're
talking well you can see the quadruple
cameras on the back 40 megapixel main
camera at f 1.6 with ois and it is a big
sensor at 1 over 1.7 inches and you also
have an 8 megapixel 3x telephoto with
ois and a 40 megapixel ultra wide at f
1.8 and it's an even bigger sensor than
the main camera at one over 1.54 inches
and then that fourth sensor is a 3d
time-of-flight camera plus the dual led
flash in my opinion now that i've
actually gotten to use this more
the ultra wide best
technical performance
of any ultra wide that i've seen in any
smartphone camera it's not the best
camera quality still it's kind of weird
with the colors but technically speaking
very impressive ultra wide the sensor is
so big that i find myself just switching
to the ultra wide and shooting with it
all the time it's not super fisheye wide
and then you can still get up close and
be near subjects and get a naturally
blurred bokeh without needing portrait
mode skin tones and overall color were a
little weird i think they could use some
work dynamic range was good though focus
was on point and of course all those
pixels give you a lot of detail that
most secondary cameras are not exactly
crushing so the primary camera is good
but the ultra wide was fun so this phone
is clearly capable of doing pretty great
things
but that's the problem is i've been
using this phone and kind of having a
hard time
doing almost anything see because of
huawei's relationship with the us right
now me importing this phone buying it
online and getting it shipped here means
i get a phone with it's android 10.0
right now and the latest version of emui
also 10.0
but with no google play services and
none of that connection to google at all
this has created the biggest delta
between awesome hardware and software
holding it back that i've ever seen no
play services means no google play store
on this phone which means no instagram
no gmail no google calendar there is of
course a huawei app store called app
gallery but a lot of stuff is region
locked and you can change your region
but good luck finding pretty much
anything of the same selection of apps
that you'd find working functionally in
the play store there's no twitter or
youtube here you can still download or
sideload other apps from their
respective websites if they host them so
like dropbox and whatsapp and things
like that and there have been attempts
to sideload google play services onto
the phone as well with varying levels of
success
basically uh you're getting really deep
into you got to know what you're doing
territory here so all this change has
brought huawei phones in the us anyway
from very good alternatives to
basically unusable which is a shame
because this is actually kind of a
really nice phone and huawei's emui
software on top of android it's never
been my favorite but it's actually
getting better too they've really gone
out of their way and started cloning
other popular stuff they've seen they
built a copy of apple's measure app
called it ar measure it seems to work
pretty decently they also have smart
display resolution switching in the
settings to save battery and an overall
much nicer cleaned up settings app which
is important with a functional search so
yeah it's not perfect but they have been
getting better but now this phone is
just clearly so hobbled by the lack of
google connection
that it's clearly not just bad for
huawei but bad for competition like this
is bad for us too so at the end of the
day this phone will be fine in china and
huawei will be fine in china where
millions of their customers are who just
don't need google play services at all
china is the biggest smartphone market
in the world they'll be just fine but
i'm just not about to go out of my way
and recommend anyone goes and imports
one of these like i did so moral of the
story a re-emphasis
on the importance of software you and me
we already knew for a smartphone you
know the build's got to be good the
battery's got to be big the display has
got to be crisp
but behind the scenes with software the
battery optimization the display's
responsiveness the quality of the camera
which you can get out of a sensor all
these things
are software
and that'll never be not important
don't forget that
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one
peace